a las doce del mediodía de un día normal
y angélica estarían trabajando como
empleadas de una tienda de jarquín pero
ahora han perdido su trabajo no tienen
suficiente comida y los constantes
cortes de electricidad
también complican el cocinar dieta
teníamos trabajo y dinero vivíamos como
todos pero con la guerra esto es lo que
ha pasado de casi todo
angélica que como era tradicional barrio
de sal y cova explica que el acceso a
las ayudas no es fácil bueno hemos
violado el toque de queda desplazándonos
a las 4 de la mañana para registrarnos
en las listas pero esto no ha sido
ninguna garantía solo pocas veces hemos
conseguido algo algún trozo de pepino de
cebolla y pan y pollo hudson polvo tono
ucrania era el granero de europa
solía abastecer de trigo al mundo pero
ahora tiene dificultades para alimentar
a toda su población muchos centros de
ayuda están colapsados según el programa
mundial de alimentos más de 10 millones
de personas necesitan comida en este
momento en ucrania pero sólo tres
misiones la están recibiendo el
resultado es este desesperación de hecho
organizaciones como el programa mundial
de alimentos están en el terreno pero el
alargamiento de la guerra el aumento de
los precios y la escasez de gasolina
siguen alterando la situación y más
ciudades necesita ayuda como también
ocurre en sabor y yo no temo que la
situación empeorará más gente necesitará
ayuda nosotros estamos intentando hacer
lo mejor como humanitarios para
ayudarles porque esto está sobrepasando
a las administraciones locales la
sociedad civil y las ong y el esfuerzo
de los voluntarios para ayudar al pueblo
ucraniano en medio de esta incertidumbre
la población que no dejó el país lucha
por su propia supervivencia